SCANDAL.
I'VE GOT TO RUN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
MEANWHILE, WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
EARLIER WROTE MAJOR NEWS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SOME
TO SUMMIT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN RECEIVING DAILY
BRIEFINGS ON NORTH KOREA FROM
HIS NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM AND I
CAN ALSO TELL YOU THE SCHEDULE
FOR TENTATIVELY THAT FIRST
MEETING WILL BE ON JUNE 12TH AT
9:00 A.M. SINGAPORE TIME AND
TAKE PLACE AT JUNE 11TH,
9:00 P.M. EAST COAST TIME.
>> NO MATTER WHAT YOU CALL IT,
ITS MAXIMUM PRESSURE THAT SEALED
THE POLICY IN NORTH KOREA?
>> THE POLICY HAS NOT CHANGED.
AS THE PRESIDENT STATED, WE HAVE
SANCTIONS ON, VERY POWERFUL, AND
WILL NOT TAKE THE SANCTIONS OFF
UNLESS NORTH KOREA AGREES WITH
US.
>> Sean: HERE WITH THE
REACTION IS WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU, ALWAYS, FOR BEING
BACK WITH US.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- THIS IS
REALLY SIMPLE ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
SO FAR, WE KNOW THAT ONE NUCLEAR
TEST SITE IS SHUT DOWN.
WE KNOW THAT HE ACROSS THE DMZ,
RELEASE THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES.
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THE
DENUCLEARIZATION.
AND AS FAR AS I KNOW, THE
UNITED STATES AND THE PRESIDENT
HAVE NOT PAID A DIME FOR ANY OF
THAT.
TRUE?
>> TRUE.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT HAS CONCEDED
NOTHING.
AND THE SANCTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ON-SITE WILL WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ON PLACE.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID ON FRIDAY,
THIS IS PART OF THE DISCUSSION,
AND HE LOOKS FORWARD TO THIS
MEETING.
HE THINKS IT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY GOOD AND PRODUCTIVE MEETING
AND IT'S GOING TO BE PART OF
THIS PROCESS, BUT HE CERTAINLY
THINGS THAT JUNE 12TH IS GOING
TO BE A GOOD MEETING AND HE
CERTAINLY IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
DOING THAT HERE IN THE NEXT
WEEK.
>> Sean: I THINK THE PRESIDENT
ALSO IS VERY SMART IN TRYING TO
MANAGE EXPECTATIONS.
NOTHING IS GOING TO BE SIGNED IT
NEXT WEEK, THIS WILL GO AS FAST
OR SLOW AS NORTH KOREA WANTS.
THE SANCTIONS REMAIN IN PLACE.
IF THERE WAS ANOTHER MISSILE
FIRED, WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT
WILL PROBABLY SEND OR STRIKE
FORCES RIGHT BACK ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA, IF NEED BE.
IT SEEMS, ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT PULLED OUT FOR A
PERIOD, HE MEANS WHAT HE SAYS.
HE'S WILLING TO WALK AWAY AT ANY
TIME.
>> 100%.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXTREMELY
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS PROCESS.
ULTIMATELY, HE WANTS TO SEE THE
NEW REALIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA.
THAT IS THE TOP GOAL HERE,
THAT'S WHAT HE'S FOCUSED WITH
THE TALKS WAS UNDER ON.
THIS MAY TAKE TIME.
THIS MAY NOT TAKE TIME OVER THE
COURSE OF ONE MEETING BUT
SEVERAL MEETINGS.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THAT
DIALOGUE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE A
COMMITTED AND FIRM TO IT.
HE HAS A GOOD FEELING OF HOW
THIS FIRST MEETING WILL GO.
>> Sean: I UNDERSTAND HOW THE
MEDIA IS, SO THE PRESIDENT HAS
KEPT ALL OF HIS PROMISES OF
GETTING RID OF BURDENSOME
REGULATION, BIGGEST TAX CUTS AND
HISTORIES, MOVING THE COUNTRY
TOWARDS ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
YOU CAN SEE THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING ON ALL ISSUES REGARDING
THE BORDER AND THE WALL.
I KNOW IT'S 500 DAYS IN.
HE KEPT HIS WORD ON JERUSALEM,
THE CAPITAL OF ISRAEL, PULLING
OUT OF THE RADIANT DEAL IF
YOU'RE NOBODY REALLY EXPECTED,
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MAN
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MA,
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MAT
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MAI
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MAS
STARTED OUT AS LITTLE ROCKET MA.
I WATCH YOU EVERY DAY AND I
WATCHED TODAY, ALL THE FOCUS IS,
YOU TOLD US IN 2017 THE
PRESIDENT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE COMMENTS OF DON JR., I'M
THINKING THAT EVERY REPORT SHOWS
THAT WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID,
THAT THE FACT THAT THE MEETING
WAS ALL ABOUT -- ALL THE EMAILS
PROVING TO BE ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT ADOPTION, THE FACT IS THAT
AT THE END OF THE REPORT, THEY
TOLD THE TRUTH.
ISN'T THAT THE BIGGER PICTURE
THAT IS MISSED TONIGHT?
>> CERTAINLY THAT IS ONE OF THE
BIG THINGS MISSED TONIGHT, BUT I
THINK THE BIGGEST STORY BEING
MISSED TONIGHT, AND I SAW TODAY
IN THE ROOM, THEY ASKED ME 100
QUESTIONS ON THE FAKE WITCH HUNT
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN FIXATED ON
THESE LAST 500 DAYS, BUT THEY
FORGOT TO MENTION THAT DON'T
LIKE ABOUT THINGS AMERICANS CARE
ABOUT LIKE THE BOOMING ECONOMY.
WE HAVE THE BEST ECONOMY WE'VE
HAD SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THEY HAVE REFUSED TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
THE STOCK MARKET IS GROWING.
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE JOBS.
PEOPLE WHO NEED JOBS AND WANTS
JOBS CAN GET THEM.
I MEAN, THE FACT THAT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT,
THAT WASN'T BROUGHT UP, THAT WAS
TOTALLY IGNORED, THE FACT THAT
ISIS IS ON THE RUN AND BEING
DEFEATED DAY AFTER DAY AND WE
ARE IN A MUCH BETTER POSITION
THAN EVER BEFORE WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT BATTLE, THE FACT THE
PRESIDENT HAS COMPLETELY REMADE
THE JUDICIARY, THE FACT THAT WE
ARE BECOMING AN ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND ENERGY DOMINANT
COUNTRY UNDER THIS RESIDENT'S
LEADERSHIP, THEY IGNORE ALL THE
SUCCESSES OF THIS PRESIDENT
AND IT'S TO THEIR DETRIMENT.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
SEEN IT AND THAT IS WHY THE